boris johnson is desperate to move on
from the partygate row yesterday mps
were debating it tomorrow they'll be
voting on it and today labour and the
smp piled on that pressure one of
kierstarm's advisers told me their
strategy is to punch the bruise
a merely mouthed apology when the
cameras roll
a vicious attack on those who tell the
truth as soon as the cameras are off why
does the prime minister think everybody
else's actions have consequences
except his own would the prime minister
like to take this opportunity to
apologize for slandering the archbishop
of the church
labour's accusation here boris johnson
may have said sorry in public yesterday
but privately in a meeting of tory mps
he was less effusive and reportedly
criticized the archbishop of canterbury
for questioning the government's rwanda
immigration policy the pm hit back
i feel he's in some kind of doctor who
time warp but we had this uh we had this
conversation yesterday he must be out of
his tiny mind he would have elected a
putin apologist that's what he wanted to
do we get on with the job while they
flip flop around
kirsten's questions today were shorter
and a little sharper than usual if we
analyze his language words like apology
cameras claimed resigned broke all pop
up you can see he is zoning in on themes
of character and honesty if we do the
same with boris johnson who at points
did seem a little touchy today he is
pivoting as usual to what his government
is doing for the british people
elsewhere the pm did admit law breaking
does the prime minister actually accept
that he broke the law
mr speaker i've been absolutely clear
that i humbly accept what the uh what
the police have uh have said when an smp
mp suggested the pm was a liar they just
want this pinocchio prime minister to
pack his bags and go
it was a commons clerk who flagged it to
the speaker and we also heard a new tory
attack line i think he's a corbin
eastern illinois he's a corbin eastern a
smart islington suit i think you'll find
mr corby doesn't have the whip it is
perhaps worth remembering boris johnson
was a long-term resident of islington
and sakir lives in camden this whole
partygate row has now been going on for
more than four months is there anyone
who hasn't made up their mind maybe not
but by keeping the story in the
headlines opposition parties are trying
to ensure it's at the forefront of
voters minds for the local elections in
15 days time